zeus vs thor who would win
who would smash the other one's face in
who is the true god of thunder and
lightning a question that everyone needs
answered
okay so maybe not everyone but it's
still an interesting point of discussion
i often see people ask and debate over
certain gods which one would be stronger
which one would win in a fight
there are several metrics and examples
you can use to present a somewhat
logical argument but most of the time it
does come down to personal preference
and bias
now it does become much more difficult
when comparing deities from different
pantheons because each culture or
pantheon essentially has its own rules
limitations strengths and weaknesses
when it comes to their deities
if we use today's example as a
comparison the norse gods are
undoubtedly stronger than humans and
possess an array of supernatural traits
however they are far from invincible
gods and yoten dying are not uncommon
events with ragnarok there are only a
few who even survive
in greek mythology god's dying isn't
really a thing
heroes demigods and lesser deities
perhaps but a fully fledged god dying is
very uncommon i've only ever come across
a handful of examples and usually it's
because zeus is responsible which means
we don't even know if zeus can die
therefore going into this we need some
sort of level playing field otherwise
it's all pointless so let's assume for
the sake of this discussion it is
possible to kill zeus but how are we
going to come to some sort of conclusion
there are four factors i believe allow
us to make an educated decision these
are strengths weaknesses weapons and
battle prowess i'll be avoiding allies
and armies at their disposal as they are
from different pantheons and it would
just devolve into a greek versus norse
war
so sit back and relax while we try and
decide who wins the title
lord of thunder
one thing that zeus and thor didn't have
to worry about was where to manage and
store their passwords and sensitive
information luckily for us mere mortals
we have today's sponsor dashlane with
the sheer amount of apps websites and
different payment methods available
online today remembering everything is a
pain dashlane allows you to store your
passwords payment details and any
sensitive information in one secure
location that only you can access
remembering your details is not an issue
as dashlane can autofill them for you on
any website with just one click powered
by machine learning and a patented
security technology dashlane is
consistently ranked as the best password
manager available you can use dashlane
on any browser or device making all
shopping experiences a one button
checkout if like me you constantly
forget passwords they will be stored for
you and you'll never be locked out again
or forced to recover them you can also
browse securely and stream content as
dashlane also provides a vpn if all of
that sounds good you can try dashlane
for free today by visiting dashlane.com
mythology50
you can also use code mythology50 to
receive 50 off if you decide to upgrade
your plan to premium
let's begin with thor
for all the marvel movie fans out there
we can take chris hemsworth's thor and
we can throw it in the trash because
it's not really thor nor is it
particularly close
now this short stubby redhead that looks
like he's about to cave your head in is
what we saw tease for god of war
ragnarok and many were rather confused
by this however this isn't too far from
thor's actual depiction
you may have ordered a heroic and noble
handsome blonde australian man but what
you are receiving is a short thick
ginger norsemen with serious anger
issues now don't get me wrong this
doesn't make thor any less of a match
for anyone it makes him even more
terrifying and unpredictable
so what are thor's strengths physically
thor was immensely strong ripping their
heads off animals and his enemies was
just an everyday thing if that wasn't
enough thought also possessed a magical
belt that enhanced his strength even
further this strength coupled with his
bravery meant thor was never afraid to
pick a fight regardless of size there
was a period of time where thor and odin
were deities heavily associated with war
so he would be more than experienced in
all types of battle as the god of storms
lightning and thunder thor possessed
some control over the elements the
extent of this is often debated
it's believed that thor governed much of
the sky including its elements the wind
the rain thunder and lightning
that being said we don't really see thor
hurling lightning bolts and smiting his
enemies down in the same way that zeus
does this could be because some tie the
idea of thunder and lightning to thor's
hammer mjolnir there are stories of the
hammer spitting out lightning but the
hammer itself does not generate
lightning we can see thor as the vessel
or conductor with mjolnir being an
extension of himself
if thor is limited to being able to
summon lightning where he stands then
mjolnir would allow him to redirect and
aim this lightning there are also
stories of thor's sheer power his mere
shout causing the rumbling of thunder he
strikes his enemies with such ferocity
that wherever his hammer lands lightning
follows
there are some abstract references such
as thor being able to create storms by
blowing on his beard he could even make
rivers boil when trying to cross them
one last thing to note is his ability to
fly we see marvel's thor fly by using
mjolnir and this is not the case he can
certainly travel across the sky but he
does this in his chariot driven by his
two magical goats now how useful or
practical this would be in battle is a
whole nother question
much like thor zeus also had control
over the elements being able to conjure
storms whenever he pleased and wielding
lightning bolts like javelins to smite
down his enemies
this control is far more absolute even
being able to control the movement of
the stars and alter the time of day
as we see on multiple occasions zeus can
shapeshift altering his size and
appearance to essentially anything
the only time we hear of zeus's true
form is in regards to the mother of
dionysus who bursts into flames and dies
however as thor is a god we can assume
this may not have the same effect
the only individual as physically strong
as zeus was his son heracles zeus had so
much power he was able to bestow gifts
and abilities to deities and humans
in terms of weaknesses there are a few
to consider the one that stands out the
most would be thor's short temper we
know that zeus is the type of god to
take full advantage of this and perhaps
goad him into an unfavorable situation
we also know that thor can be killed as
demonstrated by his battle with the
world serpent
this isn't too important as long as we
are operating off the belief that zeus
can also be killed we just can't be sure
how much or what exactly it would take
to kill him
the only real weakness that comes to
mind for zeus would be ego would zeus
dare to underestimate thor
it's hard to say but it is possible
although you'd assume someone throwing
an indestructible hammer at you at a
force you've never felt before may
quickly end any thoughts of an easy
moving on to their weapons this segment
definitely focuses more on thor we've
already mentioned his belt that doubles
his strength but the reason he needs it
ties back to his hammer mjolnir
mjolnir was created by the two brothers
brocky and sindry as part of a wager
with a loki its only flaw is its very
short handle which was caused because
loki distracted the brothers
the handle being so short to meant it
could only be wielded in one hand
however there was no one strong enough
to even lift the hammer with one hand
not even thor
the belt enhancing thor strength coupled
with his iron gauntlets meant that he
was the only one capable of using
mjolnir the hammer itself was
indestructible and would never fly too
far away from its master making mjolnir
a rather heavy boomerang
its aim was always true whenever it was
thrown it would never miss its target
mjolnir is certainly an integral part of
thor's arsenal as well as his overall
identity zeus on the other hand doesn't
really have this affinity for any kind
of physical weapon there are some
abstract references and images of an
eagle tip spear however zeus's only real
weapons of choice would be his lightning
bolts
their battle prowess and achievements
are once again quite comparable
thor's most common adversaries were the
yotner who come in all shapes and sizes
but who are often much bigger than thor
this didn't stop him from smashing them
to pieces
zeus himself is also no stranger to
coming up against enormous foes taking
part in wars against the titans and the
giants it's fair to say neither is
particularly intimidated by the size of
their enemies
thor's most famous rivalry was with
yorman gander the world serpent a beast
so big it could encircle and wrap itself
around the entire world
over the years the two had several
encounters which culminated in one final
battle at ragnarok with each one slaying
the other thor was able to kill
jormunganda however the wounds he had
sustained and the serpents venom proved
too much for even him
one could argue that zeus's biggest or
most iconic achievement was dethroning
the titans but for me it comes after
when he defeats typhon the father of
monsters typhon was created with only
one purpose to punish the olympians for
their war against the titans his mere
presence caused the gods to flee with
only zeus standing his ground in their
first encounter typhon was victorious
however he chose to imprison and torture
zeus rather than killing him a decision
he would regret zeus was eventually
freed by hermes and pan once he had
recovered he challenged typhon again
this time defeating the monster and
trapping him under a volcano comparing
these two monsters you could argue that
jormunganda was larger but typhon was
the more feared and destructive of the
two
now for the battle itself we can go over
some of these scenarios that could
possibly happen we know thor is very
strong and we know zeus is strong enough
to drop a volcano on someone but i can't
see both gods standing there and
wrestling each other thor's main weapon
is a very short hammer he wants to be
close enough to grab his enemies or
smash their heads in zeus on the other
hand primarily throws lightning bolts
which you would prefer to do at a
distance if this fight took place on the
ground at close quarters it definitely
favors thor
zeus can fly around as he pleases and
just rain down lightning bolts from
above in theory thor could ready his
goats and jump in his chariot to chase
zeus through the skies but this is
rather impractical and limits thor's
movement and capabilities if the fight
did take place here you would have to
favor zeus as knocking the chariot out
of the sky doesn't seem too difficult
i think what would actually happen would
be a mixture of these two scenarios the
best way i can describe this encounter
would be as the classic ranged versus
melee
in this scenario we have zeus flying
above thor throwing lightning bolts at
will but there are some questions one
can raise
how much would thor be able to endure
how many lightning bolts would it take
before enough is enough
another interesting point to consider is
zeus's lightning bolts themselves is
there this magical endless supply
we know it's stated that the winged
horse pegasus carries zeus's lightning
bolts through the skies and we even have
some passages describing pegasus as one
of zeus's most loyal and fearless
companions in battle carrying his
lightning bolts and remaining by zeus's
side if that's the case then there is
some hope for thor
he may remain grounded in this scenario
but myone at least gives him some
options
we know that the hammer can never miss
and always returns to its owner
therefore throwing myoneh is the only
way to physically hit zeus but it's also
the safest way how much damage this
would do to zusan how long before it
knocked him out of the sky are valid
questions you essentially have a race of
sorts
can thor knock zeus out of the sky or
even kill him with mjolnir before he
succumbs to the barrage of lightning
bolts
thor's best chance in my opinion would
be to ignore zeus at least to begin with
using mjolnir to knock pegasus out of
the sky first could in theory limit the
amount of lightning bolts that zeus has
and force him into a grounded encounter
another thing to note about mjolnir is
that this isn't marvel and you do not
have to be deemed worthy to use the
hammer you just have to be strong enough
thor's belt allows him to reach this
level but we know zeus is strong enough
to lift entire volcanoes what's stopping
him from simply catching mjolnir and
throwing it back at thor along with some
more lightning bolts if that is a
possibility then it starts to look rough
for thor
one last scenario that crossed my mind
was what if zeus took the form of
jormungander would he be able to slay
thor or would history repeat itself with
both gods slaying each other
so there are the backstories the
strengths the weaknesses the weapons and
the achievements in battle it's now time
for you to decide who would win i will
however leave you of these questions to
consider
is thor strength enough to overpower
zeus can myonair do the damage required
or will it end up being used against
thor
given the unknowns surrounding what zeus
is truly capable of is pegasus his only
real weakness
let me know what you think in the
comment section
as always i've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
you